wieso ist der mann der stunde im
internationalen kunst zirkus er kam aus
new york und bereiste am nächsten tag
gleich weiter es reichte knapp für einen
besuch im vitra museum doch eine afrika
ausstellung ohne den diesjährigen
direktor der venedig biennale ist wie
ein brot ohne butter
enwezor hat das thema afrika auf die
landkarte des globalen ausstellungs
zirkus gesetzt
heute lauscht er geduldig der kuratorin
mit der er das konzept über die seien
die modernen afrika entwickelt hat
da kann selbst like selbst like konzepte
wie recycling ideen wie umgestaltung
begriffe wie ärmlich impoverished müssen
wir neu denken um sie produktiv in die
gegenwart zu übertragen und wir müssen
unser bild des defizits überwinden dass
wir allgemein mit afrika in verbindung
bringen
design und kunst als treibende kraft des
schwarzen kontinents die ausstellung
zeigt wie aus begrenzten ressourcen
zukunftsträchtiges design entsteht und
gibt so den modernen afrika ein
innovatives gesicht
enwezor ist selber inbegriff des
boomenden afrikas in nigeria
aufgewachsen im britischen internaten
erzogen in den usa studiert landet er
mit einem heft über zeitgenössische
schwarze kunst im new york der 90er
jahren
dabei zeigt er erstmals die afrikanische
studiofotografie der siebziger jahre
sein erster großer internationaler
auftritt ist in südafrika der junge in
wesel kuratiert die johannesburg
biennale kurz nach dem fall der
apartheid
es ebnete ihm den weg für die dokumente
die den ersten außereuropäischen kurator
braucht um ein jahr nach nine eleven die
welt von den rändern aus zu betrachten
enwezor enttäuscht nicht er liefert
statements zur weltlage und thematisiert
soziale konflikte und politische
instabilität um zu handeln braucht es
ein programm zumindest aus meiner
perspektive
ich hatte immer ein programm der
veränderung und dazu brauchte es
bestimmte räume die dafür offen sind die
das begrüßt
von da an gilt ein weser als der
schwarze intellektuelle der kunst und
politik vereinen kann
und als der bestgekleidete kurator der
von einer kunst biennale zur nächsten
jagt mich interessiert es nicht in kult
des künstlers zu präsentieren um
künstlerische produktion zu verstehen
was mich interessiert sind diskussionen
zwischen formen dem projekt konzepten
und zwischen verschiedenen
produktionsprozesse
als er 2011 das geschichtsträchtige haus
der kunst in münchen als direktor
übernimmt macht den leser klar im museum
trifft aktuelle kunst produktion auf
historische relevanz wie seine
fotoausstellung über die geschichte der
apartheid zeigt
manchmal einen schritt in die
vergangenheit machen um in die zukunft
zu blicken
ich verfolge aber keine retrospektive
sicht eine ausstellung sollen nicht das
gesellschaftliche geschehen zusammen ich
will dass meine ausstellung teilhaben am
diskurs darüber was in der gesellschaft
passiert
entweder kuratiert die welt für die
diesjährige venedig biennale hetzt er
von einem kontinent zum anderen seine
künstler liste ist lang und in diesen
turbulenten zeiten suchte antworten auf
die ganz großen fragen
ich sehe mit einem klaren sie haben die
ausstellung kuratiert und haben